if the Bible says that no one has seen
God how did people see
Jesus okay John 118 everything always
comes back to like 101 level that we've
addressed a thousand times right yeah
anyway let's come back again explain
what John 118 does not mean and again
you have to have access to lexans or
even a good commentary that'll bring
this point out John 1118 is not saying
no one has seen God with the visible eye
the word seen even in the Greek can mean
perceive or understand no one has
understood what God is truly like which
is why you need Jesus to make him known
and give you that perfect understanding
of who God is it's not seeing saying
that God cannot be seen visibly because
the Old Testament is filled with
examples of God appearing visibly and
people seeing the god of Israel just for
the sake of time let's look at one
example John do me a favor go to Exodus
249-1 Exodus 249-1 just one of many but
again is fleeing this is why Lord
willing Dave and I and the rest will be
doing ongoing series we'll go in depth
on these subjects man I mean we're going
to really go in depth right now we're
just giving you a foraste Exodus 24
9-11 you said 91 right yeah 9-1 Exodus
249-1 okay Moses and Aaron nadab and
abiu and the 70 elders of Israel went up
and saw the god of Israel no that's the
typle John what's that no one has seen
God so your Bible that's a typo but it
said they saw the god of Israel wait no
one has seen God what are you talking
about dude well keep reading they saw
the god of Israel keep reading under his
feet was something like a a pavement
made of lipus laula wait wait wait wait
go they saw god with feet and something
that looked like pavement under his feet
yeah come on bro what are you talking
about we just said no one has seen God
bro you heretic why you anyway finish it
go all the way to 11 as bright blue as
as the sky but God did not raise his
hand against these leaders of of the
Israelites they saw God and they ate and
drank okay now go to the one that uh
vocab mentioned real quick go to Isaiah
6 and read verses one and five Isaiah 6
vers one and5 so I'm gonna again repeat
what John 118 is not saying and what it
is saying so to answer the question as
you go to Isaiah 6 let me repeat what it
means for Jesus to be the word of God I
pray that the Christians get it so they
can now answer the question on their own
by the grace of God's spirit well
go to Isaiah 6 but Jesus is the word
meaning he is the perfect complete
revelation of who and what God is like
apart from Jesus you cannot know God
truly as he is you need Jesus to make
him known that's why he's called the
word and Christ reveals the father in
Union with the spirit they work together
perfectly now in Isaiah 6 did they see
gone Isaiah 6 verses one
and5 John you saying you got it or you
want meita you can go ahead all right
and yeah you know that passage in John
uh another relevant one that relates to
what you're bringing out in John one is
John 646 John 646 it elaborates that
idea about no one seeing God completely
or perfectly but here's Isaiah 61 now in
the year that King Isiah died I saw the
Lord sitting upon a throne high and
lifted up and the train of his robe
filled the
temple keep going all the way to five
above him stood the seraphim each had
six wings with two he covered his face
and with two he covered his feet and
with two he flew and one called to
another and said holy holy holy is the
Lord of hosts the whole earth is full of
his glory yeah and the foundations of
the thresholds Shook at the voice of him
who called and the house was filled with
smoke and I said woe is me for I am lost
for I am a man of unclean lips and I
dwell in the midst of a people of
unclean lips for my eyes have seen the
king the Lord of hosts no no no no no no
no you're wrong John said no one has
seen God I don't know what you're
talking about you're a heretic but
Isaiah said my own eyes my own eyes have
seen Yahweh Jehovah the Lord of hosts
now what's interesting is someone just
read John 537 brought it up I don't know
if they're doing that to refute me uh do
me a favor vocab go to John 537 let's
deal with these proof texts that are
misused to prove that God cannot appear
visibly let's get them out of the way
now we're going everybody we got about
less than 15 minutes
left to get your questions in everybody
John just now before you read it before
you read it reason why I want to knock
these passages out because now it's
recorded now they can have recourse to
go back and see that none of these
passages deny that God can appear
visibly they're being misinterpreted
John 5 37 and the father who sent me has
himself borne witness about me his voice
you have never heard his form you have
never seen and go ahead finish it finish
it and you do not have his word abiding
in you for you do not the one whom he
that's it 37 you want to give me an
extra verse you can give it to me next
time 37 notice what it said read it one
more time so they can catch what you
read his voice you have never heard his
form you have never seen aha that's it
God the father has never been seen and
heard therefore you have a contradiction
in your Bible no no no Jesus is saying
that particular group standing before
him because of their unbelief that is
that evidence that they have not heard
God meaning not that they haven't heard
a word from God they haven't accepted an
act upon it because if you take this as
a blanket denial that the father's voice
has never be heard you got a
contradiction vocap go to John 1228 to30
John 12
28-30 John 12 28 28 through 30 reads
father glorify your name then a voice
Came From Heaven I have glorified it and
I will glorify it again the crowd that
stood there and heard it said that it
had thundered others said an angel has
spoken to him Jesus answered this voice
has come for your sake not for mine but
wait I thought no one can hear the voice
of God the father but in John 12:28 to30
that fairy gospel many heard the voice
of God the father so Jesus wasn't saying
that no one at any time has ever heard
the voice of the father he's saying you
haven't heard in the sense that you
haven't received and accepted it because
the same Gospel of John the father's
voice is heard audibly from heaven and
Witnesses hear it some think it's
Thunder some think it's an angel but go
to Matthew 175 let's finish it go there
let me make a brief timeout for our
atheist friends notice there that the
voice of God is heard and people audibly
hear it but even then because sometimes
people write off everyone in the first
century is superstitious believing
everything kind of people even then
people interpreted a clear Supernatural
event through a
presuppositional naturalistic framework
and say oh it was Thunder just like a
modern day atheist if they would have
been there they probably would have said
unless the spirit of God moves on their
heart they would have said oh that was
Thunder that I heard not the voice of an
audible because we can't have that so
therefore it was Thunder notice even in
the first century you have that type of
presuppositional anti-s supernaturalism
that people will always find some way to
explain it away but go ahead what is it
you said it's Matthew chap5 yeah now
before you do that look at this Muhammad
and telling me come on stop it Sam uh
all speech doesn't consist of letters
and sounds oh my goodness anyway just go
to Matthew 175 just go to m Matthew
chapter 17 verse and verse five which
reads he was still speaking when Behold
a bright Cloud overshadowed them and a
voice from the cloud said this is my
beloved Son with whom I am well pleased
listen to him no that's a typo the
father's voice has never been heard by
anyone there is no way that there the
disciples heard audibly the voice of the
father saying Jesus is my son whom I
love listen to him impossible obviously
if you read the scriptures in their
context it's not saying the father's
voice cannot be heard or the father
cannot appear visibly we know he can
Daniel 7 is an example Revelation 4 and5
other examples it simply means that
particular group because of their
unbelief were so blind and deaf that
even when the father's voice spoke to
them they couldn't discern it they
couldn't perceive it they couldn't take
it in so to end it what does it mean for
Jesus to be the word he is the perfect
revelation of God the Father apart from
whom you cannot know God as he is you
need Jesus that's what it means time up
no doubt David John add
something I mean I can add something on
the topic but um what do you mean well
I'm just saying yeah either something to
that or perhaps what do you mean or
perhaps uh you see um question you'd
like to address either one of you guys
or hey Dave what I want to say to Dave
is the guy said Allah doesn't speak with
sounds or letters
soent that's great so
so the Quran here which uh
uh how does this work right because it's
written in letters and you speak it with
sounds so if that's not the word of
Allah then thank you then we we
shouldn't believe that the Quran is the
word of Allah according to our Muslim
friends uh are telling us here